al je suis heureux de souhaiter la
bienvenue à as la tête de bois à jaaces
[Applaudissements]
Brell les
vieux ne parle plus
ou alors seulement parfois du bout des
yeux même riches ils sont pauvres ils
n'ont plus d'illusion et non qu'un cœur
pour deux chez eux ça sent le teint le
propre la lavande et le verbe
d'entend que l'on vive à Paris on vit
tous en Provin quand on vit trop
longtemps est ce d'avoir trop rit que
leur voir leszardes quand il parle
d'hier et d'avoir trop pleurer que des
larmes encore leur per le T paupièr et
s'il tremblent un peu
de voir vieillir la pendule
d'argent qui r salon qui dit oui qui dit
non qui
dit je vous
attends les
vieux Rê plus leurs livres sans
sommeil leurs pianos sont
fermé le petit chat est mort le muscat
du dimanche ne les fait plus
chanter les vieux ne bougent plus leurs
gestes ont trop de rid leur monde est
trop petit du lit à la
fenêtre puis du lit au fauteuil et
puis du lit au lit et s'il sortent
encore bras dessus bras dessous tout
habillé de rid c'est poursuivre au
soleil l'enterrement d'un plus vieux
l'enterrement d'une plus laide et le
temps d'un sanglot oublier toute une
heure la p du
d'argent qui r aus salon qui dit oui qui
dit non et puis qui les
attend les
vieux ne meurent pas ils s'endorment un
jour et dorment trop
longtemps ils se tiennent la main ils
ont peur de se perdre et se
perd pourtant et l'autre reste là le
meilleur ou le pire le doux ou le
sévère cela n'importe pas celui des deux
qui reste se retrouve en
enfer vous le verrez peut-être vous la
verrez parfois en pluie et en chagrin
traverser le présent en s'excusant déjà
de n'être pas plus loin et fuir devant
vous une dernière fois la pendule
[Musique]
d'argent aus salon qui dit
oui non
[Musique]
leattend qui rontont aus salon qui dit
oui qui dit non et
puis qui nous
[Musique]
attend